après la france et la belgique qui fait
face à la situation
la situation est claire la réponse est
claire mélanie les élèves qui porteront
le voile islamique ne seront plus
acceptés dans certaines écoles de la
périphérie de bruxelles en france
dépasse les partis politiques
l'étape et associations le clivage est à
l'intérieur il ya les pour et les contre
dans chacune de rennes a laissé le dame
gisèle halimi a présenté sa démission
n'est pas d'accord sur les choix de
cette association à la merci des raisons
pour lesquelles choisir une association
présente d'abord le point de la
situation de ce dossier
avec trois points les foulards divisé
continue de susciter polémiques ces
discussions depuis que le voilà énergie
dans les débats chaque partie chaque
famille chaque courant y va de sa
partition
à gauche on est tous le tchador et
l'école danielle mitterrand a donné le
camp à la proue il est suivi par lionel
jospin michel rocard de terminaux rim
à droite on est contre les hongrois
côte-à-côte vg les gens comprennent a
ajouté jean pierre chevènement
ils dénoncent ce qu'ils considèrent
comme une atteinte à la neutralité de
l'école
dans le même temps lisez la limited sos
racisme en soulignant que pour elle le
foulard états unis d'internement de la
femme
l'irb ou encore du voile parce que m
allez me tromper accusé l'ennemi se
trouve qu'on n'est pas en prenant comme
bouclier contre à la démonstration que
frappante et leur intégration dans tous
les cas sophie cultive qui ont très bien
des affrontements au sein du débat sur
la laïcité
même au plus haut niveau de l'état on
s'inquiète michel rocard s'est expliqué
mais françois mitterrand a pour
l'instant préféré garder le silence
qu'il s'agisse de la morale ou de la
philosophie le sujet a saisi les esprits
et dépasse aujourd'hui la frontière dès
lundi
le foulard coranique sera interdite dans
toutes les écoles communales de
molenbeek très de bruxelles cela pour ne
pas oublier que l'enseignement pour
rester milk et ne pas déroger au
principe de la convivialité